ん
4日
ポンちゃんはじめ冊はです今鳥取カメラなぁ
あの昔使っていたカメラなんですけど
先日
俺のぶっ壊した nex 5 r の修理代が車
2万円かかることになりました
上地られたんですよ俺も
お姉さんで保証書とかも ir を照射ことも付いてて
色々してあげたんですけど
ん
細1年間って気
1年間10ならー
数え修理してくれるという話だったんですけど何かあ
違ったらしいんですよ
僕のカメラのエキスお母様はなのか僕のせいラスクを少数にできないって話でした
そしたらこのカメラでいこうと思います君
dx サイバーらー外出用とがカメラトレイを専門でなんかでこの骨のは使い勝手が
良い気がすまんです
コメント日誰もがそんな悪くないんですよって言ってくださる
いう方も多くて
あーこのため等でもねー
他
いけると思いますそしたらこのカメラで今後農業
距離長女になれっ
ですねり最近よくヘッドバンドを着けてるんですけど
my loving 切りすぎて短いんですよ
切ったらもうマイナビここらへんなんで私も以上会
飽きちゃったんですよ
の少女がいやべチャルカよかなと思ったんですけどやっぱり
ローソンの該当復活して静岡最低で初めてバイトがない日なんですけど
やっぱローズが入って分かったわー
を衝撃
コンビに働いている限り
一番身近なの商品だと思いますので
でもねぇ
行けされて挿入障害っぽい感じででもう2枚ねぇですよ
うん
えっ
いうものを持っておるの
その後も私の味方か
ブービーパコン dragon ball z 神といって新しいけど
それのコラボソング人のチャンピオン開かれたから乗ってますよ
遠藤者様等の金属なぁ
4日
me
某ん
20分
言えばった a
ni
me